boom huff store look at this okay so we
are basically done with the house we got
a couple small things here and there but
for the most part we are completely
finished with the house remodel so if
you guys really want to see how far
along the house has come go check out
the first video I made I'll have a link
down in the description and you can
watch the whole thing and I might
actually tack that on to the beginning
of this video yeah I might take that on
to the beginning of this one so it kind
of goes into into the actual finished
product but anyway so so here's a master
master bathroom master bedroom I haven't
finished with this yet I'm still trying
to figure out what decorations to put up
where like over here I'm going to give
you guys perspective because it looks
small it's not this is a king-sized bed
actually it's a it's a while now I'm
sorry an Alaskan King so it's it's like
it's huge this is a massive bed it's
just because of the angle and so on and
so forth that sound back here is
actually this the steam shower
look how big that is click this up this
is me I'm 5 foot 8 look how big that
look how high that goes it's gigantic
its enormous you could fit three people
in there
and then of course the vanity and all
that kind of stuff some personal goodies
right there and this right here you can
floss it's flossing and it's a
toothbrush so that's kind of it I'm
sorry I really really dig that anyway um
here is the walk-in closet soliciting
this out here it is the whole walk-in
closet space pretty massive pretty
gigantic that right there is this is
actually dirty clothes no I'm sorry
clean clothes I haven't put away yeah
check this out but it does go in here
that slides up just like that
those are dirty clothes
[Laughter]
anyway let's see here is
the bathtub 71 inch tub massive tub say
shopping bag from Bed Bath and Beyond
right here so that's kind of nice just
doing a little bit of picking stuff up
different things like that
all right let's see yeah we're gonna
leave that light on because we are and
we're coming back here in a little while
all right let's move into the other
bedrooms this right here of course is
the guest bathroom no real difference
there the actual steam unit is under
there it's it's back under there a
little bit so anyway um yeah so a guest
bathroom and then here is one of the
bedrooms there's no real light in here
so it's pretty dark I need to install
some or set up some IKEA lights or lamps
or something but pretty Spartan in here
pretty bare-bones doesn't need to be
super high-end or anything I'll probably
end up fixing it up this is going to be
the photography room which I need to set
some more IKEA lights in here as well
but that right there is the 2013 matte
pro right here and then of course
there's some additional storage right
there and then the natural printer over
there for you know printing out stuff
work stuff but what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna fill this wall right here with
photos portraits pictures I've taken
different things like that so pretty
excited about that and then this is the
aerial shot from the top of the stairs
so I'm pretty excited about that let's
go check it out that's the water
features right there the pump still need
to be replaced
so not a great big huge deal but I'm
gonna ream somebody's ass so they don't
get replaced sometime soon there of
course is my YouTube plaque on million
subscribers so these right here don't
worry about these two marks these are
just oh god what do they call those
things maybe it'll zoom in possibly
there we go there I guess focus rather
these are what are these acoustic foam
panels so they're basically eggcarton
curtains is what you guys are here I'm
called sometime
there's Ana Cougars I'm sorry there's a
akia light there's a couple of chairs
here is the loveseat and then of course
my map of the world on the wall which
I'm really excited about
these right here are portraits of
various entertainers people like that
that I find to be really really
intriguing or interesting so here for
example is Oprah Winfrey she needs no
explanation it is over Winfrey King
James LeBron James Keanu Reeves one of
my favorite actors of all time he will
say he's the king of overacting a friend
of mine rust-eze russ is full of [ __ ] ah
this is this is the rock of course the
man the myth the legend the rock the
People's Champ and then of course here
is Jennifer Lawrence she is absolutely
stunning the problem is Jennifer
Lawrence is from Louisville and I'm from
Lexington so that means that we're we're
destined to be enemies forever and then
of course here here we have Candice
Patton yeah my celebrity crush all right
getting into the kitchen area here is a
kitchen I just got done making dinner a
little bit ago so pardon the mess it's a
little bit messier than it should be but
of course we've got some let's see just
like a chopping block
coffee maker some brown rice right here
nothing too special this right here is
actually a Marshall speaker and this
thing cranks and then of course some
various things there's part of my food
scale right there I've been losing a lot
of weight recently so I feel pretty good
and then of course there's the stove tea
maker or a tea pot rather and then you
know the best beer is an open beer which
is true and then some fruit and then uh
fateful dishes so a little bit shameful
but you know not too bad and then of
course we have the living room set of
that is Superman by Alex Ross which I
really really like that that was done
exceedingly well actually show you guys
had Captain America here in a minute but
of course we got a TV I got my guitar
and then this is where I filmed my vlogs
right here on the Rob Jefferson channel
so those guys who don't know about it
you can go check it out I'll probably
also have this video on the on the
actual Robbie Iverson channel itself so
that right there this microphone
but you should be able to see that that
is an mkh 416 microphone that thing is
very very very high standard very good
quality that is the Blackmagic 4.6 K Pro
or Ursa mini 4.6 K Pro here's my
bookshelf with all my personal artifacts
I've seen a lot of you guys ask
questions about what's on this bookshelf
curious about what kind of stuff I have
here that is the very first mixer I ever
bought which is a pro FX 8 this is my
100,000 subscriber plaque some scented
candles some books Harry Potter things
like that mostly nonfiction or I'm sorry
fiction down here and then right here is
a nonfiction stuff so there's a lot of
history stuff there so I'll zoom in so
you can see that all kinds of history
books here World War 2 was my favorite
era in history which you guys will find
out in a video that I'm releasing soon
that's my favorite point in history also
there are some things like the courage
to act by Ben Bernanke the 2008 mortgage
crisis more or less here's also some
philosophy books justice what's the
right thing to do
awaken the giant within by Tony Robbins
one of the most important books I've
ever read actually drove me to become a
youtuber helped me on the road to be
killing a youtuber a critique of pure
reason by Emanuel Khan a more
philosophical book in act as moral if
and only if everybody can do it that is
stuff for home protection if you know
what I mean that is a what is it a time
machine from Apple I don't know I have
so much Apple stuff I forget what it is
there's some hats Green Lantern comic
some other stuff that is a 70 to 200
millimeter lens great big huge lens some
cooking books very important when I was
16 years old my mom said not enough men
in this world know how to cook and
you're not gonna be one of them so she
taught me everything she knew about
cooking so that's actually a menu right
there this menu is from the Wizarding
World of Harry Potter at Universal
Studios I stole it
this is there's a fig plant from Ikea
that's my dad's American flag and then
some blu-rays and this is probably one
of the most important quotes of all time
and I'll make a video about this don't
put off your happy life it is very very
important let's see this is Batman black
mirror by Scott Snyder another fake
plant
some batteries for the camera some
camera accessories this is a menu from
American whiskey I will not say how I
did it or how I got it for fear of
getting the person who got it for me in
trouble so we will leave him out of that
but this is a audio interface the first
real one that I got from Universal Audio
co-op hollow twin and that's a camera
bag so yeah all these things on this
shelf all means something to me they all
have a very very important reason for
why they're there and maybe I'll make a
series of videos where I run over what
each of these things mean and why
they're so important to me but for right
now you can just take the fact that
they're all very important and that's
why I have them check this out this is
Captain America and pretty cool come to
America by Alex Ross one of my favorite
paintings and then this is my little
note thing that I got when I cross a
hundred thousand subscribers and then
this is the nest thermostat which I
think a Lexus hooked up I can't remember
if it is it'll set that I can tell the
set of thermostats like 67 or 68 or
whatever it is I'll just be like Alexa
set the thermostat to 70 and then it'll
do it so let's go down in the basement
into my mancave which I'm actually in
the middle of working on a video at the
moment which I'll show you guys here in
a second um right here we have my bar
space we got another spider-man by Alex
Ross we have the mask of Lucius Malfoy
we have Lucius Malfoy wand right here
which is I just know it's not Lucius
Malfoy is one that's Baltimore's one and
then of course we have superior
spider-man or Ansari superior Iron Man
autographed by Stan Lee a PlayStation 4
controller I put it there because it
just kind of looks cool actually comics
1001 of the variant covers some alcohol
you actually mix these two together
Hennessey and hypnotic and you get the
Incredible Hulk which is really good
that's my Amazon echo I need to get a
new one and then of course the Budweiser
sign the mancave sign the dish rack so
on and so forth now here's a really cool
thing I had a fan give me this and this
and that would be all three of those at
Denver Comic Con and I framed them and
hung them up because they are amazed
and I really love family of course we
got Deadpool I had this one commissioned
by a guy in New York Comic Con as well
as spider-man and then of course here's
another spider-man fighting venom and
then there's downstairs I'm sorry the
Hat there I have hats everywhere around
here you know TV down here and then
another there's an Incredible Hulk by
Alex Ross right there which I don't know
if you can really see it because of how
everything is angled but there you go
The Incredible Hulk by Alex Ross one of
my favorites and then we have the actual
workstation area which is where I edit
the videos for the Rob I am Rob logging
channel and then a lot of you guys will
probably recognize this system from
singularity computers this is the build
number 37 which he made for me which I'm
very excited about I'm actually getting
another one is Spectre build and this
there's a whatever anyway here's a
DaVinci Resolve which I'm currently
using to edit a video or at least color
great a video and then there's so many
lights so everything looks super dark
here sorry about that and then let's see
here is the recording space right here
so notice notice the sound difference in
hearing check this out notice the sound
it sounds totally different in here like
it is very very nice in here but those
are bass traps foam handles more bass
traps and blackout curtains Incredible
Hulk Iron Man some more art that I had
commissioned all this good stuff so
anyway guys um yeah this is the setup oh
one last thing I want to show you guys
this tier one last thing so when we went
to Denver Comic Con myself Sal and Benny
we all went and then we actually met
Kaitlyn there I had the idea of grabbing
one of these basically like a poster
board and having all the people who
showed up to meet us to sign it and
those are all the folks who came to meet
us at Denver Comic Con so I might do the
same thing for New York but if I do I'll
need a much bigger one because a lot of
people show up to New York Comic Con so
I might need a much much bigger one the
last time we had a panel in New York
Comic Con I think we
like 400 people so it gets pretty
Bunker's when you get a whole bunch of
folks showing up but I definitely wanted
to hang that up and I might take it down
because right now it's stuck to the wall
I might take it down and have it framed
I'm not really sure yet but anyway guys
so that's that's the house - er this is
the this is the house - is where I live
so it's pretty exciting but uh yeah I'm
gonna go ahead and bounce off here and I
will catch you all later please